you're not going to be able to pass
medicare for all
with the way that our current political
system is designed
because
you have progressive democrats who are
for it on the record you know like the
the bernie crew and as you can tell i'm
for this you have moderate democrats who
are for some version of it maybe not
really push comes to shove and what
happened in california is the moderate
democrat spiked it the moderate
democrats had which is by the way the
bulk of the legislators the moderate
democrats but there there's a lot of
corporate money and they said so if
you're a health care provider you're
looking at this being like well by and
large i'm making a ton of money off of
the the folks that have no choice but to
pay and i'm avoiding having to cover
people that are
struggling who are by the way going to
be more costly for me and can't pay so
that's a drag so let me just uh avoid
that entire population so they so they
managed to spike it now what happened in
california would happen
nationally and so if you are a
progressive who wants universal health
care your first vision is like maybe
we'll just take control of the
democratic party and the democrats will
pass it
and you have to look and say like
california two-thirds of the legislature
is democratic i got all the debt did not
pass it
so
with that as your backdrop uh i'm going
to suggest that the only way that we're
going to get something like universal
healthcare passed is if you don't have
this two-party system where both parties
are essentially locked up
by corporate money the two-party system
will never pass
medicare for all and all you have to do
is look at california and say
two-thirds democratic majority governor
who ran on it by the way
completely silent
well he didn't backtrack officially but
he just said let this bill die without
mike spending political capital so what
happened in california would happen in
the us time and time again if you want
medicare for all or universal health
care some version of the united states
of america you want democracy reform you
want to move off of the duopoly the
duopoly will never pass anything like
that
[Music]
so
[Music]
this week on forward the battle for the
soul of the republican party medicare
for all dies in california and the
importance of dads and male role models
this week on forward
[Music]
and we're back
what is going on with the republican
party
they voted to censure adam kinzinger and
liz cheney for serving on the january
6th commission and then mitt romney came
out and was like hey this is really the
opposite of what you want like these
people are
courageous standing on principle
uh centering them is a terrible look so
we all appreciated mitt trying to stand
up for his fellow sane republicans
frankly and uh it's a really
terrible sign of where the republican
party is where
uh january 6 was called i believe it was
like a legitimate means of political
expression or something along those
lines all right so i'm going to need you
to
treat me like i know nothing on this
because i've been down a boys and men
crisis rabbit hole the past week and a
half uh so i followed this a little bit
but so let's start with basics what does
it mean to censure like what is that i
saw that i
hadn't heard that term in politics maybe
in a while censure is you formally
reprimand someone you say you're bad we
don't like you just in writing slap on
the wrist yeah it's somewhere between a
slap on the wrist and like a
scarlet letter where at least in theory
would be sending a very big signal to
republican voters that look these people
are not for you they're technically like
not part of the party is that not i
don't know technically you're not
excommunicating from the party okay
you're still part of the party but
we don't like you
and do they vote on that like where does
that come from they do vote on that so
the party voted
to censure
liz cheney and what's the other guy's
name adam kinzinger kinsey where's he
from illinois illinois i don't mean to
quiz you i literally just um i'm gonna
play the every man on this um
and
she's from liz's in wyoming yeah
so they get the boot because they said
that the january sixth protest let's
call it was not legitimate political
discourse which is what the line was
from the rnc chair right well that
they're
serving on a committee to investigate
and figure out what the heck happened
and who should be held responsible and
they boot it off so ronna mcdaniel this
is the quote from rnc chair
miss mcdaniel said liz jane and adam
kinzinger crossed a line they chose to
join nancy pelosi in a democrat-led
persecution of ordinary citizens who
engaged in legitimate political
discourse that had nothing to do with
violence at the capitol now
i think she was trying to differentiate
between
the the violent protests there's a chunk
of protesters that went in there and
like ripped the capital to shreds and
had their field day and then there were
people that came to protest are like i'm
not for this i'm out um but i don't
think
she's really taking the time to
differentiate this seems more like
warfare than actually trying to have a
nuanced conversation yeah very much so
and and there's been a shift in the
conversation over the last number of
weeks where a lot of people are freaking
out about whether our democracy is going
uh to make it through the next several
years i'm certainly on that same
wavelength uh no we had stephen marsh
the author of the next civil war on and
he predicts very dark things over the
next number of months uh and i
find his predictions to be very
reasonable so
i'm
kind of happy to say that a lot of those
predictions are now making it into
journalists
papers where they are saying look guys
we should be freaking out
recently there was an op-ed asking
democrats to vote for sane republicans
in
places where they could conceivably do
so because the struggle for
the
soul or you know the essence of the
republican party is really where all the
action is and this is one of the reasons
why i think polarization is so
destructive is if you say to a democrat
hey look there genuinely are
some
sane republicans on the other side that
if they win then our democracy will
continue to function that they they
won't be
uh trying to
invalidate election results of the rest
of it and then there are other people in
republican party that are full on stop
steal two etc etc now the the problem
with polarization is that if you're a
democrat
uh and you're being asked to vote for a
republican albeit the better one uh you
really can't do it you have a very very
hard time you have to re-register
there are mechanical problems but also
there's like a massive tribal cultural
problem like a moral problem sorry
you're not even talking about the
mechanics oh yeah yeah it's like so
most democrats would not even consider
doing what what folks are starting to
suggest and recommend and there is this
vanishingly small unfortunately tribe of
republicans that are standing up for
what's right i would put adam kinzinger
and liz cheney there i would put peter
meyer there i would put
david mckinley
of west virginia mitt romney uh lisa
murkowski for sure like these are
principled
public servants who if they have the
choice i mean some of them are taking
uh measures that put them in position to
be censured
in position to be
um voted out potentially like that
they're doing it because they know it's
the right thing to do
and one of the frustrations i have is
that there hasn't exactly been a rush of
support to
bolster
the peter myers or the adam kinzinger's
of the world because if you're a
democrat it's like what am i going to do
bolster a sane republican that's not my
jam
i think that this is where all of the
action should be
is uh one big example lisa murkowski in
alaska
there is so much riding
on her election
in uh
the fall
where alaska is the first state to do
away with closed party primaries so it's
uh and
uh open primary nonpartisan you can vote
for anybody
and then it goes to a rank choice voting
and joe manchin who i know some people
hate joe manchin but joe manchin
said he's going to be endorsing
lisa murkowski
in her senate race so this is a democrat
nominal democrat
endorsing a republican
and the question is how many democrats
are going to catch on that what happens
to the lisa murkowskis
and the liz cheney's of the world is
actually
uh
existential in my opinion
so
a couple thoughts first one is this what
does the censure
or the censuring of these
what's called sane republicans left what
does that mean to the average human does
it mean that um
are they getting picked off one by one
by their own it means that the
republican party has
lost its way uh officially yeah where
someone who stands up and says look we
should investigate what happened on
january 6th then it's like you're
in the wrong got it it's all
donald's party if you will yeah or
various versions of that and marjorie
taylor green et cetera now
not to say the democrats are but i can't
tell you how many times on social media
i'll see something being like
republicans are
ex where it's like just people
uh on the democratic side just can't
stand all republicans um even
republicans that i think are some of the
more
principled sane ones they'll you know
take violent issue with the fact that
lisa murkowski didn't vote for
a particular thing
um and i've met senator murkowski
she struck me as like a very very
uh reasonable human right uh you know
and and so that there's like a
real lost opportunity shall we say like
that joe manchin is trying to
demonstrate what can happen if and again
a lot of democrats uh you know aren't
keen on joe manchin right now but joe
manchin's leaning off across and saying
look we need lucy murkowski to win and i
completely agree right so i feel like
this has been
shifting for a while and it's starting
to come to a head and it
elections like election years usually
cause that but we've talked about
kind of four parties in the united
states right now the far left far right
and then your moderate left in my right
um but i feel like there's really
almost i'm gonna say three right now i'm
curious your thoughts on the fourth is
maybe shaping but you have the far left
and the far right we know what those are
and then you now have this pro
civilization
it's not a party yet but some sort of
lane emerging where it's liz cheney and
joe manchin and kristen cinema i guess
like you could argue
there's this sort of it's like all
moderates and it's maybe you could argue
corporate democrat or corporate
republican there's some sort of
you know if you're pro-establishment or
pro-institution it kind of leans a
little corporate you know um
do you
and then maybe you could argue there's
like this rebel independent thinker like
a christian cinema who's maybe um
like a wild card in that sense but
do you see this shaping up what are your
um
are there new lanes being created here
there's an opportunity for a new lane to
be created uh i said to someone the
other day imagine if we were to raise
a 300 million dollar fund and then go to
senators
mansion cinema murkowski
uh susan collins
um and say
your party is turning on you
um if you join this new party
we will have a super pac that will
bankroll your next election at the same
level that you currently have so we'll
buy you out of your contract with your
party more or less
for the next big super pac though okay
the next election you need a very very
big super pac
um could you get four senators two
senators three senators to
bite
maybe
especially if they're at a point where
if they have to go through their own
party they're going to lose
and so
might as well
uh take a shot on the third way
uh so that this is a trial balloon idea
that uh you know like people have been
vastly entertained by um when it's been
suggested to them you could do the same
with
representatives too the the numbers
would be lower because obviously they
don't have to run as
big campaigns
but you would need a much bigger number
of them because the swing the center
right has 50 50. so if you had you know
two to four senators you genuinely could
be the fulcrum and control just about
everything whereas congress there might
be a gap of you know 10 seats or
something like that these wild cards are
complicated though because if you had
another joe manchin
you just have no idea you know like
there's he's issue by issue which i
generally like except when you're trying
to get something done
yeah i mean you know like so like i have
my own perspective on like i think we
should get rid of the filibuster i think
um for example cinemas in the wrong like
saying that it you know the filibuster
isn't trying it seems like a hot mess
but to your point
is there this
um
pro-democracy
republican
group
um like mitt romney that could be
brought in to collaborate which they're
working on this electoral account reform
act right now right yeah that to me
again is the crucial pivot group it's
that if you get enough of the same
republicans and a lot of democrats
listen to this be like there are no sane
republicans and and i will say to you
if that is true then we're in deep [ __ ]
because
uh you know like things are trending
they're gonna roll in 20 in the fall
they're
right now it's mid-february
uh a lot can happen to be fair nine
months
a lot a lot could happen
um so the economy has picked up
significantly by the numbers where
everyone was shocked at how robust the
job numbers were and everything else one
of the things that has made me
skeptical that that's actually going to
become some biden bounce
is that people are pissed off regardless
it's like if you were to say to folks
hey
jobs are plentiful you should be happy
no one's happy right now no one's happy
because
of uh omicron because of it's the winter
because of inflation like everyone's
pissed off it's very very hard to talk
someone into
feeling good
about the economic picture right now
could that change in nine months
it's possible
but
no it's a tough bet
the dems have a messenger problem and
we've talked about this before where
no real clear vision
and that vision doesn't you know the
republicans didn't
i wouldn't call it a vision from a
business standpoint but they were but
donald trump of 2016
vision of make america great again and
drain the swamp
got him to lower taxes and do some mess
with obamacare rules and you know i'm
saying it got them to be and feeling
like you got wins the price we paid to
beat donald trump in 2020 was that we
all rallied behind
objectively a weak messenger because it
was plain vanilla it was we can all
stomach this
to defeat this evil that is donald trump
is what most people were voting for
and
now we're paying the consequences and i
think
actually this is the question i wanted
to ask you
would you have
endorsed biden and lined up this way
if you knew that trump was going to run
again
you know what i'm saying like i think
what the big problem here is we knew we
know trump is still waiting in the wings
and it wasn't if you beat him the first
time he was dead right there was an
assumption that if we got him out he'd
be
embarrassed or
a loser after the brand in 2020 the job
was to get trump out of the oval office
and joe did win
uh it's quite likely that someone else
would not have won
so joe did the job
uh you're right that
he had something of a brief honeymoon
um and he's not
projecting a ton of
energy
yeah uh
it is
incredible how it just comes down to the
one human i mean i've been in the room
you've been in the room with
virtually everyone who ran in the
democratic field and so you do kind of
get
a sense as to
the
uh aura or
presence the vibe the energy the bible
the energy yes you know there are some
people where they really do give off a
particular
vitality yeah
um it's pretty wild
um
and you know we we all know that joe
performed better in states that just
didn't see him that much in person
uh his worst states were the first
states where they saw him the most right
um
it's kind of what i might where my head
was it's the price we paid
and look the republicans
you know in their eyes did a great job
of
making their the election and the loss
not feel legitimate to them right so
keep their
their guy in good standing um
but that has hurt us in that we don't
have a direction as a party
and we all know what trump stands for
and we know he's waiting in the wings um
and that's scaring a lot of people and a
lot of folks are going to stay home this
time around or flip to the other side
it's not great and it's what the party
is big time struggling with right now
[Music]
if you know me you know that i think
that your data should be yours and not
the big tech companies who just hoover
it on up and they take and they take and
what do you get back in return
agitation
many questions but they also are selling
your data
and profiteering uh and that's not the
way you should be surfing the web or
using the internet i recommend using a
virtual private network and the vpn we
recommend here at forward is
expressvpn it's the number one rated vpn
provider
huge firms use it
i use it you should use it visit
expressvpn.com
yang to get three months free on a
one-year package that's e-x-p-r-e
yang to learn more you'll be glad you
did you can just surf anonymously know
that the tech companies can't keep track
of you
what is peace of mind worth uh you know
it'll just make you sleep easier surf
easier and know that no one's keeping
track of you because you're beaming in
through some server in some far off
place that is completely anonymous
expressvpn.com
[Music]
you've said this a number of times that
politics is a horseshoe
where
the the extremes start to touch yeah
right
and
and then i had known growing up like
democrat meant something different in
the 70s than it did in the 90s um
like a kennedy democrat was different
than uh
you know a bill clinton democrat if you
will and these things start to morph and
i think we're seeing
uh morphing right now and the one to me
that is
i haven't asked you about this but i'm
curious um
your thoughts on
democrats losing ground on and
republicans becoming the party of free
speech
um because right now you have
major democratic organizations let's
call it aclu and the npr big time
against
curriculum transparency which is the
concept of anything you give your kids
you have to put available to
like online or through their state
government the acl aclu said curriculum
transparency are just thinly
thinly veiled attempts at chilling
teachers and students from learning and
talking about race in schools you've got
talks about banning books things like
that
democrats used to be all about put the
crazy books in schools they used to be
all about freedom of speech and had that
moral high ground thoughts on this have
we i don't think we've talked about this
we have not and it is interesting
it's so if you look at the
existential threats to the to the
country
armed violence uh is
a million times more likely to car come
from the
alt-right from people who
question
whether the government is legitimate or
whether it's rule should apply but there
is this
this zeal around
uh cordoning off certain points of view
that that is coming from
the democratic party that is turning off
a lot of people
uh and
it is an interesting
flip so you have many many conservatives
who are just reflexively like look no
censorship freedom of speech right and
they feel very very bent out of shape
about tech platforms
uh giving various conservatives the boot
now
it turns out that conservative content
actually flourishes on many of these
social media platforms so so it's a
little bit
uh you know it's like a little bit
strange strange but well they used to be
the party of censorship right away can't
two targets that are that's terrible
right and now
now now the biggest flash points
obviously joe rogan yeah and that's all
coming on spotify
and the the last word is that spotify is
not giving joe rogan the boot
um they're going to put some covet
advisories they've scrubbed some content
they've
committed to investing in
other types of voices right uh but there
are so many people on the left that want
to see joe gone right um and i i think
the white house actually came out or i
don't think it was joe but i think it
was uh jen saki came out and said that
they hope
joe gets uh scrubbed
which which i i found makes sense from
their perspective though because of
covid vaccine stuff right go ahead yeah
it's i i think that is the rationale
uh
but
it you're right that there there's been
like a bit of an inversion in terms of
free speech and and this is something
where
conservatives have like have a ton of
energy
and i think
fairly broad agreement from
a majority of americans
my fear is um
democrats
they generally have the moral high
ground they have the empathy card
right where you need to focus on this
community or that community or think
about the people that has been like
theoretically the ethos of the
democratic party where the republicans
are more about
yeah we need to do what's best for like
the the greatest number make the hard
decisions like not care about put
yourself up by the bootstraps let
capitalism the system work like that
you know when the democrats had felt no
this is the
at least the morally right um
thing to do even if not in practice the
right well you were some you uh
retweeted an article about how
a democratic administration chicago was
botching the roll out of universal basic
income three months nothing no updates
it's the same with the rental
forgiveness stipends so the the problem
for the democratic party is they uh
they talk about
bettering
um the common person
um but then their systems aren't
terribly efficient correct and so people
get really pissed off and fed up and it
feels hypocritical i mean one thing
that's going on right now that is going
to be such a loser for democrats is
masking in schools and at this point the
science
uh is let's say inconclusive as to
whether masks are keeping people safer
one thing i can say fairly
authoritatively as a parent
kids wearing masks affects the kids
themselves and not in a way that you
want
because a lot of the learning that goes
on in a classroom would be
responding to teachers or your peers and
a lot of the time you would use
your face for those things but you have
generations of kids that are just
looking at each other with masks on
their eyes and like do you think that
those kids are going to be
as expressive as social about three
years of this yeah like i mean and and
so
uh democrats being like mass mass mask
um and you and so there's a period
during which you could be like okay you
know we don't know what's going on
a couple weeks guys hunker down and then
after the science gets to a point where
it's like well you know what if you are
a vulnerable adult and you put your mask
on that actually
is all you need the kid does not need to
have a mask on necessarily oh oh and by
the way the numbers show that the kids
themselves like you know
not very vulnerable to serious illness
right and data is showing that having
masks on is not great for kids social
development right so that there there
are things that the democrats
talk about being for like if you were to
say hey are democrats pro kids i'm sure
democrats have been like yeah we're like
the most pro kids and it's like then why
are we doing some of these things that
are objectively not very pro kids
why are we doing things that that don't
let the resources flow through to like
the democrats are in many ways like
about the bureaucracies themselves more
than the results and then if you go to
them and say hey these results suck then
then there's never like oh yeah the
results do suck it's like oh you know
like let the professionals handle it
that's like my point is that the dems
are slowly but surely seeding the moral
high ground here
and
so i mean just this week stacey abrams
was photographed with her and in a
classroom she's not wearing a mask and
all of the kids are every single kid and
she put it out on her own platform as if
like
we're just not seeing the like the
she doesn't have to follow the rules but
the kids do it's like this blatant it's
now become like the bastion of the
conservative like anti mask movement to
see that but it's not just that it's
newsom and um
garcetti at the um the playoff game in
la not wearing masks and garcetti
literally claimed that he held his
breath breath when he took the mask off
for a photo it's these
hypocrisies um that are
chipping away and to me
if the dems lose free speech you know
which is one that is very core to a lot
of americans and has been proven to be
better than the
the alternatives
globally um
that's bad news in my opinion that's
what's good news for republicans i guess
but it's bad news if you are
aligned with some of the things at least
in theory of the democratic party you
know what i'm saying do you see where my
head is going i i do
and uh i think
i think the democrats are heading for a
loss in 22 and if nothing changes in 24
right and there are various excesses you
would like to see them
pull back on yeah
now the odds of them pulling back on
that
vanishingly low yeah
so we have our work cut out for us
um what i've been saying to folks is
that the democrats are like more
government more government government
and by the way there are a lot of things
i think people who know me know i
totally think the government should be
doing much much more in and investing
much much more in yeah so i'm not like
anti-big government the way some people
are and then you have the republicans
who are like less government less
government government stupid government
stupid um
and
most of us are in this
like we want the government to to be
really really good
even great
at the things that they are supposed to
do yes and that is not happening and
we're getting more and more fed up
um now you and i mainly me somewhat you
have
undertaken this massive challenge
they'll be like hey look like there is a
world where our government is able to
deliver at these really high levels now
that's not the world we live in yeah and
i am going to share a story that you
know i like i don't know how this is
going to grab people um but i went to
washington d.c
last week
i took the train
um i took the train back to new york and
i popped up penn station it was 10 p.m
and i said okay i'll i'll just go to the
yellow cab line and get a taxi for
whatever reason there were no yellow
cabs it was a bunch of kind of sketchy
people and like uh non-livery cabs oh
interesting um so i said at least 10 p.m
yeah so i said like a thursday yeah yeah
so i said it was a wednesday and so i
said well i don't need to wait in this
or i didn't i don't need to accept this
non-livery cabbie who seemed kind of
sketchy the rest of it i probably should
have gotten in but i didn't um and so i
just started walking and like my
apartment is walkable from pen
um
but wow was there a lot of human
struggle
on that walk
and i've walked that equivalent
dozens of times and i've never
felt the way i felt unsafe this this
past time where it was
uh it was like i actually said to myself
it's like wow like
if you were to try and draw up like a
dystopian
environment like what is the difference
between that what i'm seeing right now
uh there were so many people you know
struggling with uh substance abuse
mental health issues uh you know that
that area has
always had some issues but the issues
were never like right
like this and so when you think about
what the role of government i mean right
now i believe you're going to see
there are folks who are just losing
confidence in our government's ability
to deliver various things and and if you
have the capacity then maybe you
shift gears uh you know maybe you head
to the suburbs or whatever the heck um
or in in some cases just to another
state entirely like a low low tax state
um so you see this real grappling with
what government can and can't deliver
yeah and an increasingly incorrect
conversation around it where what you
should be saying is like hey how are
things going like can we see results
like my walk that night i mean like i
you know
can't forget about i mean i saw things
even in like that walk
where it's like
impressing your head but you don't see
things like that played out in the media
in a way like you're not showing like
quality of life issues just people make
adjustments on their own
can the democrats recover from this in
the sense so right now you're seeing so
biden did a
sort of a town hall with eric adams on
on crime you're seeing
governors around
particularly and mayors in chicago and
l.a backtrack i am so glad
that some of the
democrats in some of these cities are
coming around to the fact okay crime's
the problem is a problem is it too
little too late
i think it's going to be a massive
challenge for a lot of these cities to
get it right yeah it's always a
challenge by the way because it could be
a challenge at any time good or bad but
at this point it's a little bit like
toothpaste has come out of the tube yeah
you know it's like gonna be tough to get
that toothpaste back in yeah man you're
out dude
um
i you know it's it's my sense is that
the democrats um
have
governments
and
media institutions typically on their
side
and both of those are declining both of
those are breaking in front of our eyes
and that to me is advantage
anti-establishment and advantage
republicans right now
something very very interesting happened
in california
last week which is they did not pass
medicare for all now let me backtrack a
little bit gavin newsom ran for governor
saying medicare for all two-thirds
democratic super majority uh and there
were a lot of progressives saying let's
do it california let's lead the country
let's show we can do
and it did not come to a vote and this
was
doa dead on arrival but it was a thing
where the per the legislator was pushing
for it said look if we make them vote
for it it's going to fail
uh and it's going to be harder to
eventually do this not easier and then
people got super mad that there wasn't a
vote and people thought well if we can't
do this in california where can we do
this correct and and i want people to to
really reflect on the lesson of what
this means
so california is easily the most
progressive state
and
they couldn't get medicare for all past
what does this mean nationally now first
let me say very much on the record i am
for universal healthcare you know some
version of it
it does not make sense that we are
maybe the only developed country that
doesn't do something everyone else has
this right not everybody most of our
peers have this right
and the argument i made for this during
the campaign was our current system is
terrible for business
terrible for business and it's terrible
for jobs it's terrible for people and
families
right now if i employ someone of course
i want to say you're a contractor a temp
employee because i don't want to pay for
health care because if i do pay for
health care it is so expensive it's 800
dollars a month pretty much minimum by
the way if you're an employer that's
what it costs you and that adds up yeah
that i mean that's 10 g's but but a lot
of places it's going to be a bit higher
than that a lot that's that's like big
though and the reason why i know it's
going to go higher and higher is because
the health care industry just grows and
grows it's up to 16 17 18 18 of gdp yeah
so it's really bad for business it's bad
for the country you have to get the
costs under control
and there's a very very pro
economy pro-business
uh version of this case that can be made
so i am for universal health care in the
united states of america the thing that
uh people in in my view have to absorb
from this lesson of what happened in
california
is that you're not going to be able to
pass medicare for all
with the way that our current political
system is designed
because
you have progressive democrats who are
for it on the record you know like the
the bernie
crew and as you can tell i'm for this
you have moderate democrats who are for
some version of it maybe not really push
comes to shove and what happened in
california is the moderate democrats
spiked it the moderate democrats had
which is by the way the bulk of the
legislators the moderate democrats but
there there's a lot of corporate money
and they said so if you're a health care
provider you're looking at this being
like well
by and large i'm making a ton of money
off of the the folks that have no choice
but to pay and i'm avoiding having to
cover
people that are
struggling who are by the way going to
be more costly for me and can't pay so
that's a drag so let me just uh avoid
that entire population so they so they
managed to spike it now what happened in
california would happen
nationally and so if you are a
progressive who wants universal health
care your first vision is like maybe
we'll just take control of the
democratic party and democrats will pass
it
and you have to look and say
like california two-thirds of the
legislature is democratic i got all that
did not pass it
so
with that as your backdrop uh i'm going
to suggest that the only way that we're
going to get something like universal
healthcare passed is if you don't have
this two-party system where both parties
are essentially locked up
by corporate money this is your forward
party argument for medicare this is just
look the two-party system will never
pass
medicare for all and all you have to do
is look at california and say two-thirds
democratic majority governor who ran on
it by the way
completely silent
now yeah well he didn't backtrack
officially but he just said let this
bill die without mike spending political
capital so what happened in california
would happen in the u.s time and time
again if you want
medicare for all or universal health
care some version of the united states
of america you want democracy reform you
want to move off of the duopoly the
duopoly will never pass anything like
that at least i never it's a long time
um will not pass anything like that in
the foreseeable future right every long
time given like the the way the
mechanics are set up so i i'd like i
want people to take like the the stiff
lesson from california that one should
if you have this goal which by the way i
completely share you know it it's in
both of my last two books i was like we
should have universal health care people
consider me like a centrist or whatever
like i just want things to be better
but
break it down the current system
will not give
the american people something
significant and transformative like
medicare for all i will also say that um
to the extent that there was an
opportunity it was when obamacare was
passed and then it got
kind of uh brought back so you're for
the public option though right not true
eliminating private insurance
or you would eliminate private insurance
over time
um or keep it for the very rich or what
um whatever we have to do i mean you
know it's like i'm you know like there
are certainly versions of the plan i'm
more excited about um but uh like i
think having a public option that then
um out competes over time i mean that
that makes sense you wouldn't want to
that's what most other countries are
doing right yeah and you wouldn't want
to take an entire giant
well-developed 18 percent of your gdp
yeah and just being like yeah like you
know you know just going to scrub it off
because like at this point
uh you know there there there are
there's like a meaningful transition to
be made so does this get spiked because
people are not for government running
their health care given that they're not
for government and i mean people like
it's called moderate democrats right or
does it get spiked because most people
actually
like there's there's still a healthy
number of people that don't mind their
healthcare the read in california so
you're talking about zach as if like the
people of california came together and
said we don't want this there's
legislatures it was just that a number
of legislators were like you know not
going to do it i i have a sense that the
majority of californian voters were for
it and and so they spiked it because bad
for business bad for business because
they're donors they're getting money
from yep
so again the government system problem
and not the governor ran on it you know
it's like it's it's not like the voters
were like oh no we don't want this all
of a sudden it was just like it just ran
aground of
uh of a system that won't and we just
shrug now because i didn't see this in
the news besides that one political art
politico article maybe there are a
couple other headlines you know what i'm
saying this you'd think this be national
news
bernie sanders an entire presidential
campaign
in two cycles
second place
this is the disease right now is that
the media will segment
political figures and voters into
ideological lanes like progressives or
for
medicare for all and then you know other
people are not like the the fact is
like you know you could talk to a host
of
like reasonable conservatives who would
be into some version of it like
romneycare-ish yeah um because it's
sensible it's good for business yeah you
know the healthcare industry is just you
know like overrunning everything yeah
and we're not getting drug prices the
most one of the most popular yes
policies in there out there
so so it's the the being separated to
ideological lanes plus the two-party
system that will keep anything
meaningful from happening
takeaway here is if they can't get it
done in california they're not getting
it done it's not happening yeah unless
you change something up and that's the
dark
reality we're in and why you did why you
started the forward party that's it
right yeah the current system will not
deliver we need to upgrade the system
itself if enough of us got together to
make meaningful to make it happen we
could you know there's nothing stopping
us in a way we need to tout this more
because you know what it's lo it's not
ambiguous anymore like it's always been
you probably had enough proof but right
now you're like today
2022 like
you know how many people are in favor of
this the most liberal state in the
country can't get it done yeah that we
really should be because right now if
you ask democrats hey why can't you get
anything done the answer will be
republicans yes
in california there are there were no
republicans to you know yes there's no
way to blame but the party yes and that
was my problem with what's going on
chicago with the universal basic income
pilot it's like there's no republican
stopping this just democratic
bureaucracies doing nothing with that
money
in the middle of the pandemic
infuriating
and if
i don't know what republic would
republicans do better
probably not
um
they would do a couple things
that are easier to sell
more normal for americans yeah what we
need is effective efficient
government actually delivering and you
need better political parties to do it
[Music]
it's the winter time it's kind of gray
out there unless you are a very bizarre
soul you might be feeling a little bit
down and sometimes when you're down you
know it's going to pass but sometimes
you should really talk to someone and i
don't mean that friend that just grunts
at you i mean someone who actually is
professional and trained and can dig
into
whatever depression or stress or
relationship issues you are having and
that's why i am so proud to be sponsored
by better help
better help is helping millions of
people take charge of their mental
health by connecting them
you to a professional
mental health resource therapist someone
who actually can dig into your issues
and get you feeling better about your
life hence the name better help
i want you to be healthy
vibrant enjoying all of the things that
you should be appreciating and as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who've
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp
help.com
yang you'll be glad you did get some
help
i wrote an op-ed that
should be out by now around uh the
problems you and i have been discussing
with the last several weeks my rabbit
hole man around boys and men so tell me
about what you found out in the rabbit
hole
and we could probably do
multiple episodes on this but role
models and their impact on boys and
girls specifically dads
because i alluded to this last episode
but
and i think you may have said this in
your op-ed i can't remember because we
went back and forth a number of versions
but the number one factor
in
violent crime and the individuals who
commit violent crime
the strongest correlation and
correlation is not causation but the
strongest correlation by all by far it's
not income it's not race it's not
ethnicity it's not social economic
status
it's whether or not they had a father
and
there's something
i'm like my head's like there's
something in the water like there's
something here where
boys without a father without a male
role model and it can be replaced like
like we're talking about at scale right
so it's usually a father but but it ends
up being lack of a consistent male role
model
end up
disintegrating and that's like you could
point to that
generally as the cause like that's
what's crazy to me and we've had this
data for a while and what we seem to
blame everything else besides
that i don't know if you you saw that in
your research too or or what you think
oh yeah i completely agree and see it
you have some data points that are
staggering dude i'm gonna read these off
for the crew here please um okay
my source here is the boy crisis by
warren farrell who's going to be a guest
on the show soon um
and so but they are well sourced with a
number of resources but i'm just going
to i'm going to rattle off like high
level what we're looking at
if you
have a father that's involved
um
you are going to see
higher school achievement better grades
better verbal and math intelligence
less dropouts 71 of high school dropouts
have no father
90 of homeless youths and runaways are
fatherless
if you do not have a father you're
substantially more likely to be a victim
of abuse so that's
child abuse major violence sexual
assault domestic violence um a one
percent increase in fatherlessness in a
neighborhood predicts a three percent
increase in adolescent violence
eighty percent of rapists come from
fatherless homes
if you have no father you're four times
more likely to end up considerably
poorer in your gen when you are becoming
an adult but if it's the opposite
if you have a mother and a father you
have an 80 chance to move up if you have
a mom and a dad
it is a predictor having a father is a
predictive profile of being a bully and
being bullied because you'll have poor
self-esteem poor grades and poor social
skills by the numbers
your trust and empathy increase if you
have a father
and no dad is the greatest correlating
factor of suicide rates amongst
teenagers now the other crazy ones
they're just fun i didn't listen as a as
a dad this is making me feel
very very
uh
important yes you are massively
important you're
i'm arguing you i mean look moms are
very very important as well but the
downside risk of no mother is not as bad
as a downside risk of no father
particularly for boys i would actually
say
that
the mother
is
more likely to be present and then the
question that's good yeah yeah and then
the questions actually have that
downside risk yeah yeah i mean so single
dads uh i believe comprise something
like 12 to 15 of
single parents so maybe 85 percent are
single moms um so you know so there are
heroic single dads out there doing
incredible things yep
and look no mom's number are bad too
those are like they're not single
parents are like that is a big factor um
but the numbers are worse for no dads
and here's the two crazy ones and i'll
stop so
boys without fathers have shorter
i'm going to probably butcher the name
of this is telomere is a name of a end
of a chromosome the end of your dna
chromosomes
so it's basically how we
it has to like every time a cell divides
that little end becomes a little shorter
and so in boys without dads that is 40
percent shorter um
therefore sorry the loss is 40 percent
greater if you will it's the same than
um
uh in boys and girls when they don't
father so if you don't have a father
like father's boys are literally living
not as long
wow compared to girls like well this is
a the connection with with that
chromosome um and then the other one and
that's what i'm saying these are the
ones that like seem crazy to me but
there is data on it every single member
of isis was fatherless
essentially every single member of isis
was fatherless you mean like
americanized isis or no like over in the
middle east it's a global problem wow
yeah now there's an argument that it's
most of them america killed most of the
fathers and
mainly the sons were the ones avenging
their deaths and
fighting america but it was attracting
boys without fathers and you could go
back in history like hitler for youth
and today neo-nazis typically tend to
attract boys without fathers so anyway
this is the rabbit hole i've been down i
don't have conclusions yet um i want to
read more but
that last part was very very dark and
it's something that
arthur brooks said uh on
yeah the podcast about his book from
strength to strength he said that humans
are very worship full
and we look for things to
follow and elevate
and so if you're a boy without a father
you're kind of looking for something
to
follow
to give yourself structure purpose
fulfillment identity
community
and so if you have toxic ideologies
they're going to flourish much more in
environments where people don't have
dads and and this is something that i
would would suggest and this is going to
be a massive theme for us so we write
this op-ed i put out a tweet a while ago
that has kicked off sort of this mail
series by the way shout out to all of
our new listeners who are tuned in for
this um
because we have grown um we always are
kind of growing steadily but we've grown
um a lot more because of this topic so
thank you all for for both listening and
helping us feel validated that this is a
big concern so this is
fact-based
how we can help
families individuals societies like do
better um you put out a tweet i put out
a tweet about
failing boys and men and it becomes
politicized in a particular way which
makes zero sense
because it's just
you know just health just you want
things to to go well so this is
something where
uh republicans have had these
conservative
family values now uh like do i think a
lot of that is you know frankly not
actually being served by the policies
they advocate yes i mean your family
values you'd probably be trying to get
you i would be get people health care
and the child tax credit like all this
other stuff like that that that to me
um but uh
there there is this sense that a
two-parent home is better for the kid
um and if you were to say something like
a two-parent home is better for the kid
in democratic circles a lot of people
will get upset at you even though that's
like a very strong factual statement
they would say what do you have against
single mothers or
what's wrong with the kids with you know
or i don't know they'd probably give you
a what about ism um yeah
and and by the way most single moms say
i'd love to have some help yeah right
because there's something
around
um
pooh-poohing the traditional family unit
as kind of yesteryear and saying like
you know now
we should be having all of these like
very unconventional
um arrangements or
um maybe it's heteronormative to say
two-parent household because uh like
although obviously you know gay and
lesbian couples can have kids too
um
yeah and there's a lot of data on like
it's it's a two-parent piece it's just
it doesn't matter double-ended resources
to the child is what you're talking
about um but then there's a male role
model piece as well
um
particularly for boys
um
and so what what they were what the book
was saying is that today is so i wanted
to talk about this and i want to ask you
a couple questions but was that in
today's society women um
their opportunities have expanded right
not only where they used to you know the
traditional model was women stay home
and take take care of the kids
now they can they have the opportunity
both you know and like there's still a
ton of problems with women in the
workplace but it's a lot better than it
was right you have a lot more women
working and getting college they're not
just relying upon men for correct
they're not reliant
on men in
general right
um at least as much anywhere near as
much as they were now men it's been
actually the opposite where they used to
only have the work piece they weren't
taking care of kids and you're not
seeing as much men be dads i mean more
for sure but nowhere near is at the same
scale as women getting into the
workplace
and then
how men used to find their purpose is
going away the big two that warren talks
about were one was being the warrior
which is literally going to war and
being the hero um which we don't have as
many wars and so they're not we're not
coming back a hero and that's not
encouraged the way it was
um so that's gone and then working with
your hands which has now been subject to
automation
outsourcing things like that so you're
working in a factory or the coal mine or
those types of jobs so if those have
gone away you see men with that
disappearing purpose in many ways um
and what they're filling the void with
is
uh
destructive you know um
so anyway this is my rabbit hole um i
talked to my dad about it and he said
it's not a rabbit hole son this is the
truth this is like this is um this is
not just rabbit man
[Music]
well my question i guess a question um
thought for you man is like you have
you have not succumbed to a lot of these
kind of male tendencies that are
driving a lot of society's destruction
right like what what god would thank you
brother what was i never asked you what
how what was your relationship with your
dad growing up and did he do anything
exceptional out of the ordinary to to
focus on this
my dad
was an immigrant to this country and he
was a surly
physicist who
um was very work-centered
uh he would come home and
just
ignore us yet he had i mean he had a
couple of weird pursuits that
he liked
like he started learning japanese for no
particular reason okay um he he did play
basketball with um some chinese dads was
he tall
no he was not tall um but he he had like
a reasonable hook shot that he would
just like launch out there okay
um
he did watch sports so that that's
probably one reason why sports is a
thing what sports uh he'd watch
notre dame football on nbc first deals
like when it was broadcast because he
got his masters in physics at notre dame
before getting his doctorate at berkeley
um to the extent that i had a really
good male role model companion was my
older brother
who i felt so indebted to
because
anything he did i did and picked up uh
and how many years older he's two and a
half years older so it was such a boon
you know when i was 14 he had a car and
so we'd like go around so you know like
i could do stuff
um
he
did tennis so i played tennis he did
taekwondo so i did taekwondo
what else did he do that i i was your
dad or your mom encouraging to do tennis
and taekwondo and those types of things
um
my mom
uh
encouraged us
um just for college apps really it was
like oh you got to be well-rounded you
know i was like asian um now that my big
contribution was i got into basketball a
bit later
um and then played all throughout my
20s and 30s you know every week on a
game here in new york that was a that
was like my favorite part of the week
man and like whatever was going on that
week and saturday morning comes and i'd
go
to that gym at baruch um and
there'd be 15 guys there and we'd shoot
the [ __ ] what's funny is i played with
some of those guys for
10 12 years
no [ __ ] clue like uh what they did
for a living no it's just a basketball
thing it was just show up and we'd
we'd do our thing
um then there came a time in my 30s when
everyone started dropping like flies
where like one guy would hurt an ankle
one guy would hurt a thumb and then
every time you're like
like you know no injury that's a good
week yeah yeah i mean i struggled a lot
with my masculinity when i was younger
because i'd skipped a grade i was
smaller and scrawnier what grade did you
skip uh kindergarten okay so but it was
like but then it's forever it wasn't
like uh yeah it was forever so you know
i was your whole high school experience
i graduated from high school when i was
17 as a result so i was always kind of
uh
behind
and so you can imagine what that would
mean for me athletically because i was
the scrawny asian kid was also you're
behind everyone yeah right so i would
feel
like
a
stick figure dude like next to and and
some of the guys i went to high school
with
um weren't
enormous um i i went to high school
in an era where for whatever reason kids
discovered steroids and so that they
were like this thing where they'd come
back in the summer and just mark maguire
you're enormous um i think yeah i guess
you know like the high school football
team yeah in my town all of a sudden
just people were freaking enormous
um so so there there was like a i
remember you know growing up the entire
time
um like i i always felt
small
and so when i got to
age 17 i started going to the local gym
and lifting weights with my friend
and that was a freaking revelation
you know the the first time i lifted
uh 135 where it's just one plate on each
side it's like that's the greatest day
yeah it's a big big moment for any
dude especially if you're considered
skinny or scrawny yeah and it was fun
man because i started working out at the
gym and then i would just eat eat
anything in sight i remember and this is
when you're 17 17 18. i worked out
consistently from when i was 17 to when
i was 30 or so
where
maybe i take a month off here and there
but i would be in the gym three times a
week for those 14 years or so good for
you
did your dad work out no you learned
this from larry my dad did taiji
okay um which you know it's cool um my
brother did work out but not like i did
i ended up
taking it much more
seriously
i started doing protein shakes too the
whole nine like it was a good time i'd
eat everything in sight right i ate at
this place in new york called the pump
energy food do you ever eat at the pump
or what where is it hell's kitchen they
had a few locations i think now they're
called they got superseded by this new
chain energy kitchen okay i think i've
heard an energy kitchen yeah yeah uh
predecessor was the pump so you worked
out to feel
one you probably end up liking it over
time you get the endorphins that sort of
thing but it made you feel
like more of a man more strong yeah more
of a man like more confident yeah
stronger
uh you know those are good times i will
say when you're working out
consistently and getting stronger like
you walk down the sidewalk and be like i
can drop do a push-up right now no
problem you know like you know you're
feeling like it's almost
oddly feeling like you're invincible but
it was born of this chip on my shoulder
because i felt like my masculinity was a
question all the time and you wear a lot
of muscle shirts or like tighter fitting
clothes oh yeah
plus it was like the 90s dude actually
that was part of the game um and i my
relationship life was still pretty
bad i was gonna say where do the girls
fall in here so so i was always in the
gym like feeling sullen
i don't know if this happens to other
guys
but when you
date someone
do not go to the gym as much because
that certainly has been my pattern yeah
i did relationship weight that's the
thing that's the thing yeah so i was
single for most of that time that's why
i was in the gym all the time yeah for
sure and then uh during the relatively
rare instances when i was dating someone
then i'd ease up well you uh when you're
single
you know you're going out there's a
chance you like go home with a girl or
something so you don't want to be like
you want to if someone you never know if
someone's going to see you without your
shirt off or something like that you
want to remember you right away yeah
yeah i would have to take my shirt off
at a moment's notice yeah uh that's i
mean that's the somewhat mentality at
least before weekends i guess if you're
that's after that's what you're doing uh
you know i think that this arc though
that i went through
um
was
essential
to me
and you've talked about it a good amount
well just in the sense that
uh like i i felt
bad about myself for most of my youth
uh and it was you know i mean i was good
at school and stuff and like kids that
things that other kids valued like i
didn't value as much so people were like
oh wow good at school it must be great
and of course you're like who cares
right you know like i you know i'm like
uh the skinny kid that girls don't like
or whatever yeah um
so uh and then that ends up informing
your
uh professional life and your choices
where it's like oh i'm not making enough
money like um my failure like people
don't like me people don't
respect me uh et cetera like that there
there's like a lot of
brooding a lot of gnawing self-doubt a
lot of that stuff
um and because of that i would [ __ ] up
just about any relationship that
um like that started to go anywhere and
i'd like screw it up very very quickly
because as soon as there was some
problem
like i i would get like super down on
myself and i think the person and then i
would i would over react and this is so
this is something we probably should
talk about it's like i would overreact
by being like that sort of
needy guy who's like you know like a
little too over eager like insecure
being like you know oh like you know
does she like me and like where are you
yeah yeah even if she
you know might have liked me it's like
no one likes that guy
so women um generally tend to love
confidence as as a a big factor um
did you
during this time did you have like a
a vision in your mind of what
the man you wanted to be you know or
what you were striving towards and what
was that guy
well it was like a superhero man it was
like i want to be you know jacked i want
to have a hot girl i want to have some
sweet job i want to like you know wear
something cool i want to you know i want
to throw a party that's dope you know
whatever it was it was and you know new
york lends itself to that sort of thing
for sure um
but it does really put me in mind of and
i don't think about this as often as i
should especially as a dad
um but if you put guys in a situation
where
they never really
um
get to a point where they're you know
confident they can get a girl confident
that uh you know a girl will like them
confident that that someone's going to
find them worthwhile that stuff is
crippling crippling and and it's so
uh it's such like a massive hurdle
you know like the first time
you know like uh
you know girl agreed to go out me or
whatever it was like like this this man
of course i screwed up but like you know
like
and then when you screw it up like you
like you know like get
um
eaten alive by it for like a certain
period of days
days maybe weeks oh yeah
so there there's like a this is this
sense right now i have
that so many boys and men are at that
point where like they they don't really
feel
like they have enough to offer
and then
because of that then they're not able to
engage in a healthy way
um
especially now because if someone
engages in a less than healthy way
then
you know it's like uh
punished so badly yeah um that i i feel
like a lot of guys will just be like uh
screw it like i'll just stay at home and
you know
like uh
go online like play play video games and
like do do things that'll be a little
safer
the role model thing to me is so
fascinating where that gets seated in
you you know it's that
your pursuit of women in its own way was
probably framed by your dad's
relationship with your mom right you saw
how he treated her whether he was happy
whether it was not um
you wanted parts of that all of it
whatever it was um and if you don't have
that
somewhat of a role model model even if
it's not the greatest role model your
dad can be unhappy and maybe bickers
with your mom all the time right but um
in the absence of that it's probably
worse right um
you're going through that journey alone
you know
my parents are still together yeah you
know like uh i mean
is it like the most romantic
relationship in the world no show me
someone in there like 60s 70s 80s where
it's just like rainbows and butterflies
yeah but you know they're still
companions yeah
and
i always appreciated the heck out of my
dad as like a kind of strong provider
type yeah
i'm a very different dad than he though
you know what what what is one thing
that does happen we all become our dads
very very quickly yeah i don't know if
that is i mean you know i haven't read
about that yeah but everybody i've
always felt that like it's
my dad's quick aside my daddy so anytime
like things were expensive or like
that's like the nickel and dime you he
would always say
he'd go
i gotta pay for that be like
ka-ching
like a cash register and then like it
was i was like 25 26 and i found myself
like someone at like pinged me for money
and i was like
ka-ching
oh my god i'm turning into my father but
that and i guess that happens right
now i so my parents you know immigrants
and so
money always was a thing yeah and there
was a long period where my mom would
guilt-trip me and my brother about all
the money that was being spent on
us whatever on for whatever your mother
would my mother would okay um my mother
was incredible she was like so loving
and like
you know like always
um she's still sufficient yeah she's
still
amazing the best but she would talk
about the money a lot and then one time
not spoiled yeah and now in my teens i
was like hey mom tell you what like you
can keep track of every penny you spend
on me and i'll give it back to you at
the end with interest and then you can
just not deal with me anymore how's that
for a deal and then then
because i was trying to get a guilt trip
don't like what you know just like if
you're gonna do it like you know do it
but don't like make me feel like [ __ ]
about it all the time right and then she
was like andy you're so mean like why
would you say that i mean i was like i
mean you know it's like i mean kids are
meeting their parents yeah i know
you know my mom's incredible yeah i
really would look at my brother as like
my main role model in my adolescence and
then yeah my dad is like just like kind
of a strong
um
provider figure
yeah um
i remember one time there was like a
stray dog that was like messing with
um me and my my brother and was like
looking to bite us and we were scared
we're very young
and then my dad came running like a bat
out of hell and like he was like a bear
really you know he'd like morphed into
like form of a grizzly bear whatever
just
runs down that yard screaming at the top
as long as that dog just freaking takes
off like my dad scared the [ __ ] out of
me and my brother
just generally yeah i mean my dad grew
up on a farm in taiwan so he's had this
farmer vibe
and he would do weird [ __ ] where
like uh a deer hit his car or vice versa
it looked like the deer hit his car
because the door had caved in um and so
he then took the deer threw it on top of
the
car and then drove it to a butcher and
then came back you know
hunks of venison i was like what the
heck is all this stuff and
your dad sounds like a badass man my my
dad is a very very strong-willed soul
yeah
and i i think i got a sense of cause you
know part of part of the pressure i i
felt was like my dad went from a farm in
taiwan
to
labs of ibm and ge and the suburbs of
new york in one generation so i was like
okay i started better you gotta do your
father right yeah so like how do i go
you know how do i compare to that leap
that's tough man
maybe you're on for probably gotta run
for president yeah but i i did feel
like my parents just sacrificed so much
for me and my brother and i was like why
did you do this and it must be because
we could do something important or
significant
um and one of the things that's
interesting is like people in the asian
community a lot which is like how how
the heck did you get the inspiration to
do what you've done because it just does
not compute
it doesn't make sense from our community
that someone would just be like hey i
think i can run for president united
states uh there were a lot of folks that
just found it literally impossible that
someone could just
do that and thanks to you really man and
like a lot of people listening to this
um that uh
you know that we made something really
special happen right uh and my parents
were not excited about the campaign when
i first told them about it uh they were
concerned they were concerned about my
family my safety my
um you know money
yeah um and so it turned around but it
was because i felt like
my parents had imbued the sense of
possibility in me
and
and uh
it's interesting thinking about this
because i feel like i'm an unlikely
spokesperson for american masculinity in
some ways
um
but
one of the things that informed our
campaign a lot of other things we we do
is that we say okay there's a problem
can solve it i think i can make a
contribution let's head in that
direction let's try and get people to
see it to be energized by it and the
rest of it and there's a lot of
optimism you need for that a lot of
confidence a lot of sense of potential
yeah you know and it means that i'm you
know i've got some
uh deficiencies on the other side
um
yeah man every
strength in excess is a weakness yeah
you know but but it was it was when we
were running for president i said to
myself if i do everything right we can
do something very special if i do
everything right for two and a half
years
um did i do everything right of course
not i mean you know there were some
issues along the way but but like i just
thought you know i that the average day
of campaigning for president there were
you know like 200 micro decisions that
had to be made and you know we made a
lot of those micro decisions like you
know moderately effectively yeah um but
there's there's like uh
there have been people who've said to me
particularly
men
um where they said that you know our
campaign made them feel like more more
as possible particularly people who are
from immigrant communities they would
say like wow like you made me think that
i can do more yeah um and that's
something i was really proud of
i mean i know because of the fan mail
and things we received or
our campaign
affected men a lot and brought them out
of their shell and made them had gave
them a purpose and gave them in some
ways an explanation for what's happening
too and i want to do that again
[Music]
probably the last question on this but
do you think your dad had this outsized
success right from like peanut farm in
taiwan to
you know senior at ge wherever that you
know college educated in america right
did you think in order to did you have
any like in the back your mind was it
some of the decisions you went the
traditional path and then you got right
off it right you did the whole like
college like you were prep school
college law school then like startup
like tech company nonprofit run for
president um did you feel that in order
to
keep up maybe with what your dad did you
had to buck the trend you had to get off
the beaten path or was that well my
parents were very upset when i left the
law yeah but i i was with you in the
sense that i
i met a startup ceo uh his name was mark
jacobstein
and i just thought to myself this dude
like i want to do whatever he's doing
you know like i bet a lot of people
listening to this might have met someone
who had made that impression on them
where it's like maybe like in my case as
a startup ceo and i was like whatever
he's doing i have to try like
yeah i have to try and figure out a way
to do that
and i did feel some pressure to try and
uh what i what i said to them and myself
i was like look i grew up in the suburbs
of new york
you know i was a miserable attorney for
those five months um and i was like is
my purpose just to like
reproduce and like return to the suburbs
and once i came am i just like a salmon
you know it's like
like
like that doesn't seem right yeah i
should take a swing at doing something
really
significant try and level up
and then that didn't work and then it
was like very very distressing when my
first company failed and the second
company ran out of money and all this
stuff um you know that that defined my
20s
did you talk to your dad when the
companies had failed i would never talk
to my dad about any of that stuff are
you kidding me
never
my dad i would come home you know
occasionally and just like grunt at me
and then you know like that's like you
know that's the kind of i'm curious
about is if you didn't sound like you
guys talked about
a lot of your ambitions or masculinity
or things like that were you able to
talk to your brother about it or did you
just learn it naturally by watching him
both my brother and i had this
kind of like chip on our shoulder it's
manifested in different ways my
brother's an academic which by the way
is the hardest [ __ ] job i've ever
seen yeah it's hard job um
i thought it was a lot easier now it's
not um um so
uh but we didn't really talk to my dad
about that stuff and one thing that
happened to my dad and maybe happening
to me we shall see
is my dad when i was in my adolescence
was really mad
he was an angry dude honestly and and he
was angry
in part because
he felt like he'd been passed over for
any management jobs at ibm
and what he said was when you can't
invent anything anymore they make you a
manager so it's all white managers and
all these engineers now the truth is my
dad would have been a lousy [ __ ]
manager i mean he's like you know he's
like the last person you would put in
charge of another human being that's not
really his forte got it um but he was
pissed off and bitter about it yeah uh
and then after i left the house my
brother left the house my dad actually
went back to taiwan to work as an
executive
where they recruited him out of the lab
at ibm and said in order to put you in
charge of this department that company
ended up not doing very well and then he
went from there to academia
but he has chilled out so much more in
his older age like he went from being
very very angry to being more
happy-go-lucky jolly okay uh and
i
seem to be making that
progression
like i was so mad in my 20s and even
when i started the presidential run i
was mad
you know i'm not angry in the same way
now that i was
um and part of it is when you have a
family and kids like you know
uh you you don't want that same energy i
don't think or it might just be that i'm
mellowing out you know maybe
um there is a dad brain
there's like a different chemical
releases when you have
a child
um and it makes it's less testosterone
and more estrogen frankly um it's like
the long and short keep you around keep
you from straining for sure um
and makes you like you release certain
hormones and things when you hold
a child and the child absorbs them or
feels that energy and things like that
um
but it's interesting to me how um
frankly what you remember about your dad
and what the thing is where i'm getting
to what we need to discuss over time is
like
helping men find their purpose and find
learn how they find and understand their
purpose because when they don't that's
when you have a lot of um
the stats i'm sharing and a lot of
fathers even if they're unwillingly
doing it they help show their sons
what their purpose is and how they can
fill that and we need to evolve that
definition for men today because the
opportunities are different and that's
um
probably where we're at you know as a
country
one thing i do forecast ahead for many
many men is i think they're going to
find
a community in gaming
and then that's going to morph into
uh web 3
nfts
like
daos and different types of online
communities i think that's the way it's
going to head for a lot of men i agree
it's already heading there
and i think that the challenge is making
that community positive positive strong
healthy and whole
um and not doing what we did the last
time which is like building these worlds
without
keeping the concept of a men's purpose
in mind and women's purpose like both um
and you'd like to have
uh
a bit more of a hybrid where it's online
offline too yes url and irl
um because one
it seems like uh the extreme particular
url can be a disaster um can be but you
know the wrong irl experience is but
just as bad in some ways so
um
i'm gonna be i'm i'm not done down my
rabbit hole that's for sure oh yeah
those rabbit holes very deep and you
know i don't think we've uh
solved for american masculinity yeah but
if you all have suggestions um
the single biggest thing i'm going to
say to anyone listening to this who's
struggling in this dimension
is to exercise preferably outdoors uh
multiple times a week
you can have the shittiest lousiest day
in the world i had so many shitty lousy
days in my 20s i still have them yep and
but if you get some exercise in then you
will always
know that you did something that day
that you can
be proud of that's good for you
you just feel so much better just like
just you know if you're listening to
this and you know you're struggling at
all just force yourself to do some form
of exercise preferably outdoors
uh you know like when when i have these
kinds of days
i will just run and it's not like a good
run either it's like an embarrassing run
you know
like but but just run it to a point
where you're
uh sucking wind and whatnot um
and studies have shown that that stuff
makes you feel a lot better it eases
loneliness and depression to some extent
you'll feel better about yourself
and it's healthier i a thousand percent
agree i would recommend
look if you can afford it getting a
workout classes or i said if you live in
new york there's something called class
pass i think used to exist um or a
peloton or but even if like if you're
like money's tight there's
youtube channels that have somewhere
where you just play and there's a
trainer on there for 20 minutes 30
minutes and half to me like it's hard to
stay motivated like that but i'll get up
and like press play and then like i just
like work me dude or go whoever the
instructor is just i'm just doing
push-ups or burpees whatever it is and i
know if i just like
get through this 20 minutes i'm gonna
feel good about myself yes um and i did
it this morning and if you have it
available to you go to a gym like go to
a gym with your friend
like i i went to a gym randomly this is
a number of years ago but i saw these
two dudes in there working out they must
have been like 20 years old and it
reminded me of when i first went to the
gym with my friend
andy george who is my you know my my
high school buddy um like just having a
dude go with you to the gym if you're
living in a place where that's a thing
uh it's you know you like you'll have a
harder workout than if it was by
yourself for sure a thousand percent
you'll go you'll reinforce each other
you'll both feel good about yourselves
so so that's that's a very elevated
thing but uh you know if if you can't go
to a gym with a friend just try and get
a sweat in somehow yes amen
um hi folks more to come
good episode we'll see you
next week oh um thank you for playing
therapist and having me unpack my
development as
the strapping man
you see before you uh you know i think
about a lot as the father of two boys
and like my boys
my boys are growing up so differently
than i did and my brother did it's a
different time i tell myself that all
the time
i i think about it a lot but that way am
i concerned about it too yes my like
concerned about
you know things that i could be doing
better like also yes but you know from
what you've cited apparently just the
fact that i'm around a dad's gonna be
kind of a big win biggest takeaway from
that book is like what's the what's
needed to be a good dad to help your son
in particular
show up
show up
does it be around love them that's good
advice for a lot of things
what is it what do you well at least in
this case virtually like show up
virtually yeah show up virtually log in
that's our show folks see you next week
[Music]
you